[Musique]
Michel COG Chantal Hébert Michel David
bonsoir bonsoir la photo de famille de
ce gouvernement de monsieur Legault je
le répète pour ceux qui étaient pas avec
nous il y a 30 ministre dont 10 nouveaux
venus donc le tiers nouveau et les deux
tiers ce sont des ministres qui soient
restent dans leur poste
ou soit change de portefeuille on va
commencer par quelqu'un qui reste dans
son poste qui est le super ministre
fitzguiben ministre l'économie il se on
lui ajoute la responsabilité
d'Hydro-Québec on va entendre monsieur
Legault sur Hydro-Québec et on revient
parler de Monsieur Fitz Gabin ensuite
pour atteindre cet objectif là
il y a une société d'État
qu'un rôle crucial Hydro-Québec j'ai
parlé j'ai changé avec la PDG
d'Hydro-Québec au cours des derniers
jours avec sophie Brochu puis on partage
le même objectif
nous assurer qu'il est au Québec
évolue de façon ordonnée pour le
bénéfice de tous les Québécois y compris
bien sûr pour les prochaines générations
on va régler le code Diderot puis
ensuite on va parler du sa
responsabilité de Montréal mais au
Québec il y avait eu de la friture sur
la ligne c'est le moins qu'on peut dire
Michel seoger parce que monsieur fait du
Gabin disait
sophie Brochu là je résume mais il veut
amener le plus d'entreprises possible
qui veulent consommer beaucoup à bas
prix on deviendra pas le Dollarama du
monde pour le pour notre électricité là
Monsieur le goudron on a un comité on va
on va on va faire des on va faire les
les négociations nécessaires que
pensez-vous de cette nomination là
ce qui était honnête moi j'ai jamais vu
ça en tout cas c'est de créer un
comédien ministériel et d'éviter la
présidente d'Hydro-Québec assiégé comme
ça a été un ministre ce comité-là c'est
Monsieur LEGO a clairement vu qu'il
allait avoir pas mal plus que de la
friture ou utiliser votre mot Patrice
sur la ligne entre monsieur petit et
Madame Brochu et à la fin je posture que
le gouvernement il gagnerait si c'est
Madame Brochu qui s'en allait à la fin
de surf alors on peut prévenir ça c'est
clair mais en même temps voici un comité
qui est fait essentiellement de grands
ministres économiques avec le ministre
de l'Environnement qui reste le même
ministre de l'Environnement que n'est
pas super performer dans le gouvernement
précédent faudra voir les résultats mais
un comité ministériel avec un président
de la société d'État
l'idée c'est que Madame brochure n'était
pas sur la même longueur d'onde et le
monsieur Legault a PAC il va les mettre
ensemble il va il va gérer il va il va
arbitrer ouais ben il essaie de mettre
sur pied un organisme un comité qui va
essayer de pacifier
mais il va y avoir des arbitrages à
faire à un moment donné bon monsieur
Legault lui-même et membre du comité
donc c'est lui en dernier ressort qui va
faire les arbitrages mais il est pas dit
que les arbitrages vont faire l'affaire
soit de l'un soit de l'autre et si
quelqu'un part moi je pense pas que ça
va être monsieur fait du Gabin alors on
verra l'usage mais ce comité-là ne
garantit pas la paix pour 4 ans là il
faut pas voir ça comme ça et Monsieur le
goût dans ses remarques a été très clair
l'économie la création de richesse c'est
la base de tout alors le premier mandat
de Monsieur fatigue c'est de créer de la
richesse il faut dans la mesure du
possible harmoniser ça avec la
transition énergétique mais je pense que
dans la tête de Monsieur fuzzle lui-même
s'il y a à faire un arbitrage entre la
création des choses attention économique
énergétique disent c'est le premier
terme de l'équation qui va l'emporter
ouais c'est ça et c'est ça que
l'équation allez vous l'avez bien
expliquée je fais ce début ne veut le
plus d'emplois possible et Madame Brochu
dit c'est très bien mais nous mais
surplus énergétiques il faut pas que ça
serve à attirer des entreprises pour
nous prendre nos téléspicité à bas prix
je résume mais c'est ça le défi les
seuls débat
néanmoins l'objectif de monsieur Legault
et l'objectif de la création de ce
comité-là à part de faire des arbitrages
sur ce genre de question là c'est quand
même de réussir à mener à terme
l'aménagement de nouveaux barrages au
Québec et dans ce comité il y a quand
même un rapport de force qui va pas
toujours dans le sens de Monsieur fils
de niol le ministre aux relations avec
les communautés autochtones et ça a
peut-être pas l'air du plus gros
ministre sur l'organigramme mais dans le
cas d'un barrage on l'a vu dans le code
Grande Baleine entre autres et pas
seulement c'est quand même
un secteur où il va falloir aller assez
délicatement le ministre l'environnement
c'est aussi important dans le sens où
autrement ils vont y en avoir des
évaluations environnementales elles vont
venir d'Ottawa alors même si le ministre
l'Environnement du Québec est faible il
va en arriver un autre
en deux surplus très franchement moi non
plus je l'avais pas vu un comité comme
ça avec la direction des dos Québec mais
peut-être que si à l'époque de grande
baleines on avait fait ça on se fait
arrivés à des meilleurs résultats que
l'impasse dans laquelle le gouvernement
est Hydro-Québec se sont conduits ça va
être vraiment intéressant à suivre ce
comité puis la suite des choses
Hydro-Québec très bien fait de Gabin il
y a un autre chapeau il y a plusieurs
chapeaux l'économie en général il y a il
est maintenant la voix de Montréal
Michel David au Conseil des ministres et
ne voient forte même si c'est Terrebonne
la voix de Montréal
est un Montréalais fondamentalement
alors ça pas grand importance sauf au
plan du symbole parce que ça souligne en
rouge l'absence pratiquement totale de
la CAQ sur l'île de Montréal et ça
souligne au passage que celle qui était
responsable de la métropole
durant le premier mandat madame ou là
pas fait son travail mais pour la
métropole de façon générale je pense que
c'est mieux d'avoir un ministre puissant
qui est en proche de l'île sur la
couronne nord que qu'une ministre faible
au cabinet et qui a son côté à Montréal
alors c'est une bonne nouvelle pour
Montréal bon il s'agira de voir comment
par exemple avec Madame madame plante
comment les relations vont vont
s'établir c'est disons que c'est des
gens qui ont une philosophie un peu
différente mais c'est Félix Gabin mais
qu'elle était ravie a-t-elle le choix
que d'être
ravi mais on verra mais mais
c'est mieux un ministre influent quand
un poids plume à la table du Conseil des
ministres le message c'est que François
Legault
va pas aller bouder dans son coin en
disant vous avez pas voté pour moi tant
pis pour vous on a déjà entendu ce genre
de discours là pas nécessairement à la
CAQ mais dans des élections précédentes
au Canada et c'est quand même beaucoup
plus de poids pour l'avoir de Montréal
je dois vous dire que dans les milieux
d'affaires à Montréal là on sort le
champagne ce soir Michel C Montréal
arrive au gouvernement là
oui il y a un bon côté un mauvais côté
de mon côté c'est que passe-moi
l'expression anglaise
quand tu veux quelque chose se passe il
y avait une application d'être un peu
pour le doseur mais ça va se passer
alors ça pour les dossiers de
développement économique il y a pas de
problème ils ont le meilleur joueur et
là-dessus madame plane doit être tout à
fait mais les dossiers de Montréal
actuellement c'est pas juste les
dossiers économiques c'est l'itinérance
c'est le logement social c'est la
violence par armes à feu c'est plein de
choses comme ça et ça vous associer pas
ça d'emblée à Monsieur feldyber alors à
un moment donné
l'économie de Montréal va plutôt bien
c'est à peu près le plein emploi à
Montréal etc au Québec mais je dis c'est
pas ça qui va trop mal ce qui va mal
c'est le transport c'est le transport en
commun particulier alors est-ce que
Monsieur Felix va être la personne pour
regarder les dossiers plus sociaux qui
économiques qui sont des vérités en tout
cas de l'administration Montréal c'est
ça que madame rouleau qui reste
responsable d'une partie de ça
d'ailleurs à autour de la table du
Conseil des ministres autre sujet qui
touche Montréal mais qui touche tout le
Québec mais qui touche beaucoup Montréal
Christine Frechette qui est responsable
de ministre de l'Immigration maintenant
clairement
Chantal Hébert un changement de ton puis
on le veut aujourd'hui monsieur Legault
dans son discours ce qu'il a expliqué
changement de ton on veut dire
savez-vous c'est positif après tout
l'immigration
après tout c'est le après tout vous
ajoutez mais qui va vraiment dans la
phrase pour ceux qui ont écouté la
campagne électorale il y a deux raisons
d'abord oui monsieur Legault a besoin de
rebâtir des ponts avec les communautés à
la femme et autres parce qu'il en a
brûlé lui-même plusieurs dynamités mais
aussi si monsieur Legault veut faire
avancer ces dossiers sur l'immigration
il y a besoin de convaincre des gens à
la Chambre des communes qui sont pas le
Bloc québécois donc le Parti
conservateur entre autres de l'appuyer
dans sa démarche parce que dans le
moment il y a réussi à faire le vide
autour de lui il y a pas un politicien
qui va être premier ministre du Canada
qui va se lever demain matin en disant
au Québec ma priorité c'est de donner
raison à François Legault sur
l'immigration pourquoi parce que la
campagne électorale pas juste fait des
dégâts ou des dommages au dessus social
au Québec elle en a fait à la réputation
du Québec dans le reste du Canada et sur
la colline parlementaire salle de rendu
un petit peu moins fréquentable
maintenant et d'ailleurs monsieur
Legault est un sujet connexe a tenu à
parler en anglais aujourd'hui la
communauté
anglophone le ministre des Finances Éric
Girard sera responsable des liens que la
communauté anglophones Michel David
clairement aussi on met la on met la
[ __ ] douce sur le dossier de la
l'immigration pour en parler mais la
langue également avec Monsieur Robert je
suis responsable de ça oui
[Musique]
on peut s'occuper d'améliorer la qualité
de la langue et cetera mais il y aura
pas une réouverture pour resserrer la
loi 85 la loi 101 disons alors il y a un
changement de ton qui est manifestement
souhaité par monsieur Legault oui et
c'est ça immigration
langue rapport avec Ottawa aussi
Monsieur Robert je vais s'en occuper
Michel C il y a il y a un changement de
ton pied une volonté de se recentrer sur
l'économie on le disait plutôt puis on
va en parler après sur la santé
puis aussi un immigration de volonté de
recoller pour casser il y a quand c'est
pas mal de pots pendant campagne
électorale ça va être difficile de
recoller tout ça madame frichette
était président d'une chambre de
commerce donc elle est sensible aux
arguments des milieux d'affaires sur les
questions des migration ça c'est déjà un
bon point mais tout le reste du du
Conseil des ministres c'est des volonté
de calmer le jeu et
c'est vrai que Monsieur Lebeau existe un
gouvernement de continuité puis les
acteurs il y a pas donné le mandat de et
ça va mal brosse la cage en même temps
la continuité dans le temps va être
beaucoup différente ça va être beaucoup
moins revendicateur puis beaucoup moins
parler nationaliste mais beaucoup moins
nationaliste au sens strict du mot et
plus d'ouverture moi je pense que j'ai
saisi un peu ce message là
vous êtes pas le seul effectivement
pendant
il y a comme cette idée que il a établi
des choses sur le nationalisme une fois
établi là on peut pas se replier mais on
peut être moins
qui a utilisé ce Chantal ou chez David
abrasif les deux vous deux vous avez
utilisé ce mail ok Michel avant moi
santé santé il y avait je sais pas si
vous entendiez on était à Sainte-Justine
un reportage il y a quelques minutes
210% 300 % hier soir les urgences qui
déborent bon c'est pas nouveau vous
allez me dire mais quand même il y a des
encore des feux à éteindre en santé et
là c'est la continuité c'est Monsieur
Dubé qui doit donner qui doit poursuivre
ces réformes parce qu'il y en a
plusieurs Michel C
demain matin
mais c'est un gros défi
c'est un gros défi il fait elle est pas
changé le ministre à ce moment si ça a
été une erreur mais en même temps il y a
pas grand chose qui a été amené pendant
la campagne électorale qui était des
solutions les hôpitaux privés là ça
marchait on le saurait
si le privé pouvait faire des profits
intéressants tout en restant dans le
système d'assurance santé on le saurait
alors il y a on est vraiment dans une
situation extrêmement difficile à chaque
fois que le moindre problème de santé au
Québec comme la grippe qui s'en vient le
système est pas capable de de s'en tirer
c'est un problème pas réglé c'est un
problème qui a pas de solution en vue on
souhaite bonne chance à Monsieur Dubé
mais c'est pas nécessairement quelque
chose qui est parti pour faire des
changements majeurs Michel David on
j'entendais ces deux mères en larmes
dire fait 13 heures je suis je comprends
que il y a pas de solution miraculeuse
si on y avait une on l'aurait fait mais
il améliorer les choses quand même on
est condamné à améliorer les choses
qui est à l'origine de tous les autres
s'il y a autant d'encombrement dans les
urgences si les listes d'attentes sont
trop longues c'est qu'il y a une pénurie
de personnel et si je pense la clé de
tout ça c'est ça et c'est ça à quoi
Monsieur
monsieur Dubé et Madame Bélanger aussi
devront s'attaquer on en sort pas là il
faut des infirmières on a déjà annoncé
qu'on va former plus de médecins mais
tout ça ça prend du temps alors on
pourra on peut pas s'attendre à ce qu'il
y a des résultats là
miraculeux dans la même dans l'espace
d'un an c'est vraiment une tâche qui va
s'éplaner sur tout le mandat et
la difficulté ça va être de convaincre
les gens de patienter parce que les
résultats ils seront pas là aussi
rapidement qu'on le souhaiterait alors
c'est un très très gros contrat à la
fois d'efficacité mais aussi de
pédagogie
vous avez remarqué que monsieur Legault
parle moins souvent des demandes des
provinces pour plus de financement
fédéral je vous dis pas qu'ils ont
renoncé mais le problème c'est que même
si demain matin monsieur Trudeau
écrivait un gros chèque ça réglerait pas
le problème ça ferait pas apparaître des
infirmières des médecins des préposés au
bénéficiaires c'est beaucoup plus
complexe que ça d'autre part c'est une
crise qui est à l'échelle du Canada on
voit la même chose en Ontario ou en
Colombie Britannique donc la pandémie
objectivement a empirer la situation
du système de santé canadien pas
seulement québécois il y a pas de modèle
où on peut dire maintenant faire des
bois un portage choisir regarder eux ça
marche puis nous ça marche pas sauf que
eux ils peuvent recruter des infirmières
des médecins c'est pas difficile à
trouver qui parle anglais le problème au
Québec se pose à un peu différemment
merci
ok dernier tour de table avant de se
quitter est-ce que c'est un exercice
réussi équilibré
il a Irus imprimé de la nouveauté tout
en étant dans la continuité tour de
table râpé de Michel David oui je pense
que c'est réussi pour une raison très
simple c'est que déjà monsieur Legault
pouvait disposer d'un noyau solide là
qui a fait ses preuves pendant le
premier mandat et que contrairement à
2018 il y a fait élire beaucoup de
députés qui qui avait de la capacité
d'occuper des postes au Conseil des
ministres il y en a fait quand même
réduire quoi une dizaine là et il y en a
encore qui pourrait aspirer à l'être
alors il y avait des éléments pour faire
une pour une réussite Chantal
oui sur papier le Québec dans le moment
sinon la plus performante
potentiellement équipe ministérielle au
Canada certainement proche du haut de la
pile quand on compare avec des provinces
qu'on peut avoir
ils vont prendre cette extrait là
chanter ça va être dans les dans tous
les Michel c'est gratuit
effectivement c'est un cabinet qui est
renforcé aujourd'hui c'est très clair en
même temps il y a deux choses qui
doivent se changer c'est le ton si on en
a parlé beaucoup mais c'est très
important que le temps change et
deuxièmement il faut aussi que monsieur
Legault discipline un peu des fois
lui-même qui a fait foirer des choses
par des déclarations un peu
intempestives tu sais il faut faire
attention à ça quand le Premier ministre
qu'est-ce que vous voulez c'est lui le
patron oui et ça donne le temps pour
tout le monde et voilà merci beaucoup à
vous trois on a fait le tour je suis
content merci à très bientôt au revoir
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI